[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay un campo en el que china todavía es
incapaz de competir con los eeuu un
campo donde eeuu sigue siendo el líder
mundial indiscutible ni china ni japón
ni ningún país europeo se acercan me
refiero a la universidad da igual el
ranking que miréis en todos ellos las
universidades estadounidenses ocupan
casi todos los primeros puestos tener un
título de yale stanford o element y
parece una pasarela segura para los
mejores trabajos muchos pensaréis que en
eeuu estarán orgullosísimos de sus
universidades que todos los estudiantes
van felices y sonrientes al campus
sabiendo que les espera un futuro
brillante
sin embargo atentos a esta noticia los
estudiantes protestan por las subidas
del precio de las matrículas mientras
las universidades continúan dando clases
online y diréis pero por qué protestar
los estudiantes tiene algo que ver con
el coronavirus antes ganas tienen de
volver a las clases presenciales pues
nada de eso las universidades
estadounidenses pueden ser fantásticas
pero tienen un problema
de la matrícula
en las últimas décadas el precio de la
universidad en eeuu se ha disparado la
matrícula cuesta hoy en día el triple
que hace 30 años para que os hagáis una
idea estudiar en harvard yale puede
costar más de 50 mil dólares de
matrícula y diréis péric cómo se paga
todo esto seguro que muchos ya sabéis la
respuesta sobre todo los que veáis este
vídeo desde los eeuu con deuda
en este país dos de cada tres
estudiantes está en deuda para pagar su
matrícula cuando acaban sus estudios la
media de lo que deben es de 29 mil
dólares repito esto es la media de lo
que deben gastarse se han gastado
muchísimo más la deuda estudiantil
acumulada por 45 millones de
estadounidenses se ha disparado al
billón y medio de dólares y si decimos
billones en castellano en inglés sería
trillions y más de uno os preguntaréis
esto es mucho es poco pues la verdad es
que es un auténtica pasta es más que el
pib de un país como españa o en otras
palabras sólo hay 12 países que
conseguirían producir en un año sin
coronavirus lo suficiente como para
saldar la deuda acumulada por los
estudiantes universitarios de eeuu
todo esto es especialmente doloroso
cuando lo comparamos con europa donde
estudiar en la universidad sale
prácticamente gratis para el estudiante
ah
de hecho el problema con el precio de la
universidad es toda una prioridad
política si no hubiera sido por el
coronavirus se habría hablado largo y
tendido de este tema durante las
elecciones presidenciales de 2020 de
hecho algunos candidatos en las
primarias demócratas como bernie sanders
presentaban propuestas como estas el
senador estadounidense bernie sanders
propone un proyecto de ley para una
matrícula universitaria gratis y el fin
de la deuda estudiantil así que la
pregunta es por qué la universidad es
tan cara en los eeuu cuáles son las
diferencias entre el modelo
universitario de eeuu y el europeo hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
el camino hacia la clase media
hasta la segunda guerra mundial la
universidad estaba reservada únicamente
a las élites pero todo cambio durante la
guerra el presidente roosevelt quería
que sus soldados tuvieran un futuro
mejor tras arriesgar su vida en europa o
en el pacífico así que dos semanas
después del desembarco de normandía
aprobó la ley de reincorporación de
soldados si a lo que supuso esta ley le
sumamos la prosperidad que hubo tras la
guerra nos encontramos con que eeuu se
convirtió en el primer país del mundo en
el que las clases medias fueron a la
universidad es la cristalización del
sueño americano poder mandar a tus hijos
a la universidad entonces que el camino
más seguro hacia la clase media alguna
forma de educación superior hasta ahora
cada generación ha vivido mejor que la
de sus padres hay cosas que se han
vuelto muy asequibles la tecnología
viajar ver visual políti pero también es
verdad que hay dos cosas importantes que
se están encareciendo una barbaridad la
vivienda y la universidad
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero porque la
matrícula se ha disparado a precios tan
prohibitivos la ley de la oferta y la
demanda da una buena explicación el
número de estudiantes universitarios en
eeuu se ha duplicado en 50 años no sólo
hablamos de ciudadanos estadounidenses
sino también de extranjeros más de un
millón de personas en todo el mundo
viajan cada año a estudiar en los you es
el y muchos os preguntaréis pero de
verdad hay jóvenes de todo el mundo
dispuestos a gastarse una auténtica
fortuna con tal de no perderse las
míticas fiestas universitarias pues
vamos a ver aunque yo no descarto el
factor de america mpaa y creo que hay
otros motivos para explicar el atractivo
de la universidad estadounidense en
escuelas de eeuu ocupan ocho de los diez
puestos principales en la lista de
jueces news de las mejores universidades
del mundo en 2020 sí ya sé lo que me
vais a decir guau fuenseca un ranking
hecho en eeuu que dice
seamos los mejores vale aquí tenéis el
ranking de la universidad de shanghai
como podéis ver con las banditas la
conclusión es más que obvia
igual el ranking que cojas las
universidades estadounidenses son las
más prestigiosas del mundo punto pelota
y ya se lo que estaréis preguntando cómo
se hacen estos rankings de verdad se
puede medir lo bien que enseña un
profesor acaso
miden el número de aprobados pues
atentos porque aquí llega el auténtico
quid de la cuestión medir la calidad de
un profesor tanto clase es difícil lo
que sí podemos medir es su calidad como
investigador sus publicaciones en
revistas la cantidad de veces que le han
citado etcétera etcétera etcétera así
que quién necesitas si quieres que tu
universidad esté arriba en el ranking es
muy fácil dinero dinero para tener los
mejores laboratorios pero sobre todo
dinero para tener a los mejores
investigadores para que os hagáis una
idea la mitad de los gastos de una
universidad como harvard se van a pagar
al personal por hacer una comparación un
profesor de universidad en españa' en el
mejor de los casos puede ganar unos 80
mil dólares al año en harvard la media
ronda los 200 mil dólares al año y
diréis pero y cómo se paga todo esto de
dónde viene el dinero pues atentos
gráfica como podéis ver las
universidades se financian con
donaciones millonarias de antiguos
alumnos fondos públicos que
fundamentalmente premian la
investigación y las matrículas de los
estudiantes en otras palabras que los
estudiantes gastan un 27 por ciento de
su pib a la educación universitaria muy
por encima de la media de la ocde que es
del 16 por ciento y diréis qué significa
todo esto pues que buena parte de esta
carrera tecnológica la están financiando
los estudiantes pero atentos porque ésta
no es la única mala noticia para los
alumnos estudio la mitad de los
empleadores no creen que la universidad
prepare a los estudiantes para el
trabajo lo que está claro es que en este
modelo universitario de eeuu todos los
profesores están más preocupados en
investigar que en dar clase porque la
investigación es lo que les da prestigio
y no la docencia mientras tanto qué está
pasando en europa pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
el modelo europeo
la principal diferencia entre el modelo
universitario de eeuu y el europeo es
que las mejores universidades de europa
son públicas pero cuando decimos
públicas es una forma de decir que la
matrícula es a ver no es que sea gratis
pero sí es un regalo comparada con las
públicas de eeuu porque si en eeuu
también tienen universidades públicas
son las llamadas universidades estatales
pero la diferencia de precios es salvaje
el precio medio más bajo de una
universidad estatal es de más de ocho
mil dólares sin embargo en españa la
matrícula más cara es la de la
universidad pública de cataluña que se
sitúa en los dos mil 800 dólares y
quiero recalcar que he comparado lo más
barato con lo más caro
estas diferencias obedecen
fundamentalmente a dos cuestiones la
primera es que en europa el estado cubre
aproximadamente el 80 por ciento de lo
que cuesta cada año la matrícula en la
universidad pública y lo que para todos
sus alumnos con independencia de que
vengan de familias ricas o pobres la
segunda cuestión es que no hay tanto
afán por investigar se da mucha más
importancia a la docencia
pero es que incluso las universidades
privadas europeas son mucho más baratas
que las estadounidenses
el precio en medio de la matrícula en
harvard yale o el mit es de 50 mil
dólares mientras que la matrícula más
cara en la universidad de navarra en
españa ronda los 18 mil dólares
y diréis cuál es la ventaja del modelo
europeo pues que no es habitual ver a
gente endeudada para pagar la
universidad y alguno me dirá pues yo
estoy endeudado bueno pues vale si algún
caso hay pero no es lo normal ahora bien
que sacrifique europa al tener
universidades tan baratas pues que la
universidad no investiga y como no
investiga es poco atractiva para ver
universidades de la unión europea en los
rankings globales tienes que bajar al
puesto 26 y encontrarás la primera
universidad danesa al 37 verás a la
primera francesa y al 47 la primera
alemana para ver una española o una
italiana tenemos que irnos a más allá
del 150 y claro cuando uno ve dónde
están las universidades de europa en
estos rankings globales entiendes por
qué la comisión europea tiene este tipo
de preocupaciones la unión europea
prepara un competidor europeo para
google con nuevos datos y propuestas de
inteligencia artificial los proyectos de
investigación son muy pobres y con muy
pocos fondos europa tiene un modelo de
universidad muy social muy asequible
pero con estos mimbres
hace un gigante tecnológico tipo
facebook lo ideal sería tener una
universidad que investigue más pero que
sigue estando al alcance de cualquier
bolsillo y diréis qué modelo se está
imponiendo en el mundo y lo que es más
importante es posible tener lo mejor de
ambos mundos pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
dos modelos en lucha
[Música]
ya sé lo que muchos estaréis preguntando
en este momento de verdad merece la pena
gastarse tanto dinero en una universidad
de verdad estudiar en la universidad es
garantía de tener un buen trabajo el día
de mañana pues si miramos los datos la
respuesta que encontramos es que depende
de entrada el 30% de los estudiantes en
eeuu abandonan la universidad antes de
terminarla eso significa que han pagado
los primeros años de matrícula para nada
claramente en este caso gastar tanto
dinero ha sido una mala inversión pero y
qué pasa con los que las terminan pues
depende del título y de la universidad
no gana lo mismo un ingeniero en
telecomunicaciones que un licenciado en
historia del arte y no gana lo mismo un
graduado de yale que uno de la
universidad de nevada
el sueldo medio de diez años después de
conseguir un título en harvard se sitúa
entre los 80.000 y los 90 mil dólares
sin embargo en otras universidades
privadas el sueldo medio está alrededor
de los 40 mil dólares es decir que es
más o menos lo mismo que ganaría si
estudiarás en una universidad estatal
que es más barata en otras palabras que
elegir una universidad no sólo implica
que muchos estudiantes se endeuden
también implica un riesgo enorme
dependiendo de la universidad que elijas
tendrás un trabajo word
así que qué proponen políticos como
bernie sanders para solucionar este
problema pues muy sencillo gasto público
a nuestra propuesta que cuesta 22
billones en 10 años será pagada en su
totalidad por un impuesto sobre la
especulación the wall street
en otras palabras bernie sanders quiere
que el estado pague todas las matrículas
nuevas y todas las deudas de los
estudiantes hablamos de esos 22 billones
de dólares en 10 años y a partir de ahí
la casa blanca tendría que pagar otros
48 mil millones de dólares anuales para
pagar las nuevas matrículas para que os
hagáis una idea hablaríamos del coste de
organizar 3 juegos olímpicos todos los
años año tras año
como os podéis imaginar en un momento
donde eeuu ya está gastando a manos
llenas por las ayudas de coronavirus no
parece que vayan a poder gastar aún más
en las universidades y diréis entonces
no hay ninguna ayuda pública para las
universidades pues sí sí que las hay lo
que pasa es que no son ayudas directas
sino préstamos del estado a intereses
muy bajos para que os hagáis una idea el
92 por ciento de toda esa deuda
estudiantil de la que os hemos hablado
son préstamos de washington por ejemplo
una de las fórmulas más usadas es lo que
llaman el pay pay as you ver cuando
terminas la universidad devuelves el
préstamo a washington dándole el 10% de
lo que ganas en tus salarios y terminas
de pagar toda tu deuda
genial para todos ahora bien si no te va
bien en la vida y no has podido devolver
la deuda en 20 años el estado te perdona
el resto a este tipo de programas están
acogidos 8 millones de estadounidenses y
diréis es problema resuelto entonces de
qué se quejan pues porque precisamente
este tipo de ayudas han contribuido a
disparar aún más los costes de la
matrícula como los estudiantes pueden
pedir créditos para pagar
las universidades no dudan en pedir
cantidades astronómicas por la matrícula
en otras palabras que parece que por el
momento no hay una solución perfecta a
este problema es muy difícil conseguir
lo mejor de ambos mundos el americano y
el europeo
sin embargo sí que hay algo que podemos
decir si hay un modelo que se está
imponiendo en todo el planeta ese es el
de los eeuu por ejemplo
arabia saudita ha invertido unos 10 mil
millones de dólares en crear una
universidad siguiendo el modelo
estadounidense y cuando qatar quiere
impulsar su sistema universitario no es
que copien el modelo estadounidense no
no no es que directamente hacen esto las
universidades estadounidenses están
construyendo un oasis académico en la
ciudad de la educación de qatar
georgetown y northwestern son algunas de
estas universidades que tienen su propia
sede en qatar yale tiene sede en
singapur la universidad de nueva york en
shanghai y en abu dhabi en otras
palabras que parece que el mundo
prefiere matrículas caras a cambio de
liderar en investigación seamos claros
silicon valley no existiría si no fuera
por la universidad de stanford y lo
mismo ocurre en muchas otras áreas y
eeuu es líder en tantas tecnologías se
debe en buena medida a que han sido
capaces de financiar investigación
científica y esto es gracias a las
universidades
palabras la universidad ha demostrado
que es el mejor lugar para investigar la
pregunta ahora es y de verdad es el
mejor lugar para aprender es decir
seguirá siendo tan importante tener un
título universitario para conseguir un
buen trabajo en el futuro este es tema
para otro vídeo pero este va a ser un
debate que dará mucho de qué hablar en
los próximos años atentos a esta noticia
google apple y otras 12 empresas que ya
no piden a sus empleados un título
universitario así que ahora turno para
ti crees que el modelo universitario va
a cambiar crees que nuestros hijos
tendrán que endeudarse para pagar su
universidad
o tal vez terminen sacándose un título
de google podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]